une idée de promenade de visite pour ce
week-end de la pentecôte c'est un jardin
des mauvaises herbes que je vous invite
à visiter maintenant c'est à chaumont
sur loire dans le cadre du festival
international des jardins
c'est une curiosité claude crespo
jean-louis mme la sueur au trèfle
panaché planta chardon orties chiens
dans les mauvaises herbes sont les
passagers clandestins de la nature mais
avec un petit coup de pouce on peut les
apprivoiser et cela donne ce parterre
ornementale bien ordonné et d'ailleurs
selon vincent un des jardins de chaumont
mauvaise c'est plutôt subjectif comme
qualificatif riz cultivé des traits fins
on voit si on se met à avoir des eaux
zayas en voilà on n'en veut pas laisser
si on avait voulu limiter les audiences
à ce cas le trail qui serait devenu
l'âme désirable sur cette parcelle
le visiteur sera comme un lilliputien
pour apprendre à repérer 28 espèces
comme beaucoup de comestible à
l'intérieur d'une cuillère géante
on utilise les bâches pour empêcher les
mauvaises herbes de pousser et là en
fait c'est que l' inverse puisque on
veut parler des mauvaises herbes et du
fait que ces mauvaises herbes se révèle
bonne quand la mauvaise herbe deviennent
design ça dérape carrément la mauvaise
herbe là ce sont ces fleurs de plastique
couronné par une forêt de cercle war
pour l'occasion à chaumont on a redonné
vie à 600 espèces et le pépiniériste qui
a rendu possible ce miracle cet olivier
spécialiste de la mauvaise graine lui
parle d'herbes sauvages
il y la nature comme un séminariste son
bréviaire
vous avez une super belle plante là
c'est la grande consoude et elle sert à
plein de choses et médicinales pour
cicatriser les plaies lé alimentaire
très très bonne entrant pour la feuille
des poilus dans dans de la pâte à crêpes
la pâte à crêpes accroche dans les poils
vous la faites frire à la poêle avec un
petit peu de jus de citron et c'est très
bon et pour mieux prouver ses
allégations
il entraîne françois-xavier puis les
chefs à chaumont dans la campagne pour
une quête initiatique où on peut entre
jeu pop tantôt mandats maire ouais un
peu artichauts
voir cette herbe la bardane finir en
recettes originales et délicieuses des
huîtres pochées avec du chou cru et cuit
des zags et du curcuma de barda et quand
la mauvaise herbe devient amie savoureux
plutôt sympa comme denjean ce nom